un jour je viens d'où la commémoration
des événements de septembre 1870 un
souvenir connu sous le nom de
l'insurrection du sud pour la ctm
collectivités territoriales de
martinique
c'est un temps fort très fort
lorsque nous avions pu au moins la
décision de nous et c'est la nouvelle
que la cua et l actuel nous comble ce
témoignage est le même que pour le 22
mai d'où le combat mené par le peuple
qui a donné et permis d'aller vers la
voie du progrès de la justice de la
dignité
une sorte de contribution à l'évolution
de l'humanité
pour marie-hélène léotin se souvenir
c'est mieux construire données de base
de fondement pour pouvoir créer vos
prochains où l'avenir
quand c'est sale ça serait con de nos
rations et tous les pays toutes les
nerfs surtout les peuples le peuple
martiniquais
une commémoration ou de nombreux
martiniquais ont tenu à honorer la
mémoire de celles et ceux qui se sont
battus de toutes leurs forces et perdu
la vie pour remettre en question l'ordre
colonial et la société post esclavagiste
des hommes des rôles des héroïnes comme
inhumaines à sophie plus menace office
et de ses vols à l'arrivée pour les
martiniquais
quel que soit l'âge aujourd'hui mais il
nous faut c'est des traces des traces
dans notre paysage
un appel à projets sera lancé afin de
construire un monument digne des hommes
et des femmes de septembre 1870